i asked you to name the most important
uh example of racism and you gave white
cops going after black people and i and
i told you gave you the facts for that
so that's nonsense you must have
something else what else is it if you
think racism remains a problem in
america give it
i guess this week is a lawyer a writer
and host of the aptly named larry elder
radio show larry how's it going well
great dave thank you for having me i
appreciate it yeah thanks for coming in
i've been trying to make this happen
with you for a while dodge josten you
forever
caught up with me i i got you i got you
you've been in this studio before right
i have i've got hosted for larry a
couple times larry king that is harry
king that's that's a larry man he has a
thing in his country the full hour yeah
he could
he can only have people with the name
larry that's right i guess those were so
that worked out for you uh so there's a
lot of stuff i want to talk about and in
in the beginning of the show i set up
that i am a liberal you're a
conservative my condolences
maybe by the time this show is over we
can move you to the center a little bit
and maybe by the time the show's over we
can it's not gonna that's not gonna
happen
but that's what it's all about that's
why i've wanted to have you on the show
because i find there are some people in
the public space that i disagree with
but that i'd like to sit down and talk
about some of the ideas and and i
consider you in that in that case um but
before we get to the politics
i like the audience to know a little bit
about the history of the people i'm
talking about so can you just i know you
were born in la right give me a little
larry elder history born and raised in
l.a my dad was a janitor he cleaned
toilets
my dad was born in athens georgia
doesn't know who his mother is it
doesn't know what his father is rather
my name elder was the name of some dude
who was in his life the longest
my father was kicked out of his house he
was 13 years old by his irresponsible
grandmother and was on his own from that
point on
my mom grew up on a farm kind of
aristocracy for for a black woman she uh
owned the farm they owned the farm
anyway my dad and my mom got together
and moved to california in the 40s
i have two brothers i am as you
mentioned a lawyer
born and raised in l.a and went to
college in the east coast law school in
the midwest stayed in ohio for about 17
years came back to l.a about 22 years
ago got into tv and radio and i've been
doing it ever since there you go all
right so now we got we got the meat of
what you do
now you're not a practicing lawyer right
negative no yeah i did it for two and a
half three years and that was it i find
a lot of people uh in the public space
either were lawyers at one time right or
i know there's a ton of comedians that
were lawyers what is it about lawyers a
lot of them want to get out what's that
i'm not sure that's true it's just a
real flexible thing to do you learn how
to reason you learn about the law you
learn about the constitution uh if
you're a trial lawyer you learn how to
think on your feet and it lends itself
to doing other things but most people i
know who went to law school at least the
ones i went to law school with stayed in
the law yeah so was that a perfect segue
to get you to be someone that talks for
a living right like instead of having to
litigate it in a courtroom you could
litigate it on air and bounce back and
forth with people and that's right
although most lawyers are not trial
lawyers it's kind of the image of most
lawyers is that they're glib and fast
most lawyers sit behind a desk and fill
out papers they're tax lawyers or or
constitutional lawyers or contract
lawyers or something like that only
about 10 of lawyers
end up going to becoming litigators and
even a smaller number of those actually
try cases yeah all right so now let's
talk about conservatism let's do it so
i've mostly been calling out the left on
my show because i consider myself part
of the left right and i've seen the left
sort of really go off the deep end to
the left and i haven't been happy about
it
so i haven't talked that much about the
right i've had a couple people on the
right so first off
uh
how would you define conservatism what
do you think that even means at this
point in america in 2016 what is a
conservative well i don't mind being
called a conservative conservative i
don't consider it to be a four-letter
word but i really call myself a
libertarian
i believe in article 1 section 8 of the
constitution which gives the federal
government a small number of things to
do dave uh meant money uh put together
an army um
deal with the borders a handful of other
things that's it
welfare health care abortion same-sex
marriage doctor-assisted suicide all the
social issues that the supreme court
takes up in my view they shouldn't take
up in the first place that should be
happen done on a state by state basis
that's what i think most conservatives
believe as well
so i'm with you on a lot of and i
definitely have some libertarian beliefs
myself i think most people are
libertarian they just don't know it the
founding fathers were libertarians the
founding fathers drafted a document that
said
our rights come from a power other than
individuals
and government doesn't give us our
rights we give government our rights and
power and everything else should be left
to the states and the individuals that's
how the constitution was started that's
how the country was started and i think
that's how most americans really feel uh
when they really think about it
i want to get this right so i want to
look at my notes for this according to
this
you are black
is that correct that is correct that is
correct not african-american that's not
a term i like you how come you don't
like the term ridiculous i was born and
raised in america i've never been to
africa uh uh how why am i an
african-american most of my people have
been here longer than most of other the
other people in this room uh yet most
people don't have a hyphen uh you know
i'm an italian american greek american
romanian-american it's an absurd term
it's a term that jesse jackson is almost
single-handedly crammed down the throats
of our media and after jackson began to
talk about why blacks should uh have
some connection to africa all of a
sudden new york times l.a times all of
the media began using that expression
it's ridiculous yeah i mean i personally
don't use the term african american that
much because one time i had a guest on
the show and i referred to her as
african-american she said well i'm
actually jamaican so you know what i
mean so i guess that that goes to your
point so and i remember reading one time
dave somebody uh was given a description
of some suspect who had done some crime
was running away uh and he was described
as an african-american how do you know
where he was from it could have been
from africa from jamaica could be from
canada so what do you think what do you
make of that when someone like because i
know you really rail against jesse
jackson and these guys on the left that
use and i want to talk a lot about
identity politics okay so the guys that
use these phrases what what are they
going for there
well they're what's their goal the goal
is to
tell black people that we're victims
that discrimination and racism remain
major problems in america when in fact
they don't
and
they want black people to vote for the
democratic party the democratic party
gets 95 of the black vote uh and the
reason they get it is because blacks are
convinced that the number one issue
facing the country right now is social
justice
racist white cops uh discrimination
systemic racism microaggression whatever
new word they come up with and it's a
bunch of nonsense the number one problem
domestically facing this country is a
breakdown of the family and president
obama said it i didn't a a a black kid
or a kid not just a black kid a kid
raised without a dad is five times more
likely to be poor and commit crimes nine
times more likely to drop out of school
and 20 times more likely to end up in
jail so you're far more likely to end up
in jail without having a dad than you
are because of a white racist cop right
so but you wouldn't not acknowledge that
there are some systemic issues give me
an example tell me what you think the
most synthetic racist issue is what is
it
well i would say that because black
people in most cases in many cases were
descendants of slaves that racism as a
as an institution that it just in 2000 a
certain amount of it just exists 2015.
give me the most blatant racist example
you can come up with right now um i
think you could probably find evidence
that
in general
cops are that cops are more willing
to
shoot if the uh perpetrator is black
what's your data then white what's your
basis for saying that last year well
look i know a lot of people would say
look what's going on in china i know
what they would say i'm talking about
what the facts are 965 people were shot
by cops last last year and killed four
percent of them were white cops shooting
unarmed blacks in in chicago in 2011 21
people were shot and killed by cops uh
in 2015 there were seven uh in chicago
which is the third black a third white
and third hispanic 70 of the homicides
are black on black uh about 40 per month
almost 500 in the per year last year in
chicago and 75 of them are unsolved
where is the black lives matter on that
the idea that a racist white cop uh and
shooting unarmed black people is apparel
to black people is bs is complete and
total bs and and the reason for these
so-called activists saying this is the
assumption that racism remains a major
problem in america the media cnn
especially msnbc runs down whenever a
black cop shoots somebody uh and it and
it's some some march on washington it's
ridiculous uh black people half the
homicides in this country are committed
by and against black people last year
there were 14 000 homicides not talking
about suicides i'm talking about
homicides
half of them were black 96 of them black
on black of that 7 000. where's the
black black lives matter people on that
so that there's where you would say that
this is purely because of social justice
purely because they want ultimately for
people to be angry enough to just keep
voting
democrats that's right and where's
where's the evidence of a lack of social
justice when a black
suspect is killed by by a cop
believe me the media is on it people are
watching it uh and uh and justice will
will for the most part occur in
baltimore where freddie gray was killed
uh freddie gray died in a van i
shouldn't say was killed died in a van
you have a city that's uh 45
black uh city council is 100 democrat
the majority of city council is black
the top cop at the time was was black
the number two cop was black the
majority of the command staff is black
the the mayor is black uh the ag is
black uh and yet here we are talking
about racism i mean it's it's absurd
yeah absurd so it's funny i find myself
caught in between this a little bit as a
liberal where i want to always try to
defend the other so in this case the
other being black people i'm always
sympathetic to that and that yeah yeah
at the same time i hear you laying out a
pretty solid well just the fact i'll
tell you something else too there was
just a study uh uh university of
washington uh and it turns out cops were
more reluctant more hesitant to pull the
trigger against the black black suspect
than a white suspect uh probably because
of the fear of being accused of racially
profiling and the fear that the civil
rights establishment was going to come
down on him so if anything uh whites are
more likely to be shot by a cop under
under certain circumstances than a than
a black person and in the last 30 or 40
years
the number of percentage of suspects
killed by cops who are black has
declined 75 percent however the
percentage of whites killed by cops has
flatlined yeah and so if anything people
are more concerned about shooting black
people for fear that they're going to be
called racist and almost all every one
of these incidents whether it's eric
gardner in in new york who died because
he was selling lucy's and resisted
arrest whether it's tamir rice in
cleveland who was twirling around the
gun whether it's michael brown and
ferguson
who had just committed an strong armed
robbery almost every one of these
incidents involved somebody resisting
arrest why don't you just do what the
police tell you my dad said when i get
pulled over have my hand at ten o'clock
have my hand at two o'clock say yes sir
say no sir make sure my paperwork is in
order and if i feel the cop is uh
mistreating me get a badge number and
deal with it later on if jesse jackson
and al sharpton and obama and the whole
group of them told black people to do
that we'd have a lot fewer of these
things to deal with in the first place
yeah all right so i'm i'm with you i'm
hearing a lot of what you're saying here
so as a black conservative then who now
you've you've laid out your case there
but you haven't laid out yours i asked i
asked you to name the most important
example of racism and you gave white
cops going after black people and i and
i told you gave you the facts for that
so that's nonsense you must have
something else what else is it if you
think racism remains a problem in
america give it to well i think it
remains a problem
it may not be systemic in that we have
it's not like you're not being hired
because you're black there's no systemic
reason you know legal reason that that
exists that kind of thing but i think
that racism as a general
uh i need some theory i need somebody i
need some specifics right you gave me
the white cop thing what else give me
another example what do you think is a
problem
well well
as a black conservative tell me how do
you know how do you get people to come
around you're the one who made the
assertion that you think racism remains
a major problem in america i asked you
to give me an example you gave me white
cops going after blacks i as far as i'm
concerned you didn't hold it up very
well what's the other argument you have
what what's the other thing well i don't
know that it's systemic in that in the
sort of macro section i'm not mad i
we have a race we have affirmative
action so a black person with a with an
sat and a gpa
of x will will get into a school faster
and easier than a white person with an
sat
or a gpa of x and if going to going to
school is a route to the middle class
you can make an argument that blacks
have an easier route to middle to the
middle class if you're talking about uh
blacks about poverty
the poorer you are the more accessible
loans and grants are for you uh the the
the problem the biggest burden that
black people have in my opinion again is
the percentage of blacks 75 percent of
them that are raised without fathers
and that has every other social negative
consequences connected to it crime not
being able to compete economically in
the country being more likely to be
arrested that's the number one problem
facing the black community and when i
hear people tell me about systemic
racism or unconscious racism i always
say give me an example and almost nobody
can do it do you think that despite what
you've said about
president obama do you think that now
that he's out of office maybe he could
step into the role that you'd like to
see him in so instead of america turning
to jesse jackson and farrakhan and
sharpton
maybe they can turn to you but if not to
larry elder but if not to larry elder
that maybe obama when you disconnect it
from politics can actually talk about
some of those things because i mean you
addressed it a second ago you said he
did mention the family and mentioned
fathers and all that so is there a
chance do you think there's a chance for
that i'm not optimistic because uh in
his last press conference he talked
about we still have a great deal to do
on race by the way when people talk
about a great deal to do on race all
they really mean is how black people
feel about white people and vice versa
they don't care about hispanics they
don't care about asians they really care
about the relationship between blacks
and whites um
and obama has throughout his eight years
in my opinion when he could have ignored
the race card or put it in perspective
picked it up whether it's cambridge
police or whether it's trayvon martin if
i had a son who looked like trayvon
whether it's invoking ferguson whether
it's hiring somebody like eric holder
who's lecturing the country on race and
racism
obama i think believes that racism
remains this huge massive problem in
america despite his election and despite
his re-election and i don't and so i
don't think he's going to say the right
thing and do the right thing i think he
i think he's encouraged black people to
think of themselves as victims as
opposed to saying look at me i busted my
butt
my parents uh made sure i had a good
education i didn't make bad moral
mistakes i got married before i had kids
follow my model and you'll be fine he
has not said that at all what he said is
we have real problems in this country he
embraced the black lives matter movement
i mentioned trayvon martin i mentioned
some of the other things in my opinion
the reason that a lot of people voted
for obama was because they thought he
was going to do exactly what you
suggested which is to heal us put things
in perspective
tell young black people they ought not
be angry when they're pulled over by a
cop all the cop is doing is his job
instead he did the opposite so i'm not
optimistic at all that he'll play that
kind of role that you suggest yeah so
the way we've demonstrated i hope i'm
wrong yeah i i hope you're wrong too i i
don't know but the way we've demonized
cops as part of this i agree i mean i
see a lot of times people are just
screaming about how evil cops are and
they're hunting people down all this
stuff
i don't know a ton of cops but i knew
some in new york and i know a couple
here i mean
generally they're trying to do good
right i mean
do you have any experience in which have
you ever been pulled over and
i probably have been pulled over maybe
more than almost anybody you know i got
my driver's license when i was 15 and a
half my learners permit and then when i
was 16 i was able to drive by myself and
i probably looked like i was 12. so i
got pulled over probably a hundred times
and with the exception of one or two
instances uh the encounter was brief and
professional uh one time a cop told me
to take my head out of my ass
that was the first time i got pulled
over by the way yeah i was driving and
there was a light behind me and i knew i
hadn't done anything anything wrong so i
sleep going the guy pulled over and
screamed at me and he goes why didn't
you pull over and i said what i said to
you well obviously i didn't think i did
anything wrong and he said whenever you
see some lights behind you you pull over
get your head out of your ass and he was
right i should have had my head ahead of
my ass
you know um uh the instances in which
cops kill blacks has declined 75 percent
in the last 45 years according to the
cdc while the instances in which cops
are cops kill whites has pretty much
flatlined and so
it's going down it is very very very
rare for the cops to kill anybody let
alone an unarmed black person of the 965
people that were killed by the police
in 2015
less than four percent were white cops
killing an unarmed black man it is very
rare by contrast 400 people were injured
by lightning last year but only 250
people were killed black people were
killed by police so it's very very rare
so how much of this i know you talk
about fake news and i want to get to
that but how much of this is
because the media is complicit in all
this so for example just this morning i
think the oscar nominations were put out
i haven't even seen them yet but
apparently there are more minorities
this time i guess there are some more
latinos and dev patel and and some more
black people right and you know for the
last couple years there's been this
oscar so white thing
to me
and i can only speak for myself this is
like keep your eye is just off the ball
you're just paying attention to the
wrong thing where
it's nice to have people nominated for
these things but they're irrelevant in
the scheme of what's important uh what
you should be caring about is education
and all that but the media has made such
an importance out of this that it's like
it's getting the black community's eye
off what's actually important which
would be education and family and some
of the other i i i couldn't agree with
you more um i have an actor friend and i
said why is this important to you
and he said because it provides role
models and enhances the self-esteem of
black people that's what he said
i said are you aware that black boys and
black girls have higher self-esteem than
white girls and white boys this has been
tested for decades it's been the case
for a long time and there are very very
few asian actors and actresses yet uh
asian americans japanese americans
chinese americans and korean americans
on a per capita basis make more money
than virtually anybody else in this
country so it's utterly irrelevant yeah
and for us to pay attention to this and
it's also not true if you look at the
last 15 years or so roughly 10 or so of
the nominees for the major categories
have been black people they've been a
couple of years where where there's been
a shutout uh but um add it all up it's
about parity with population right so
that's the irony it actually it's within
a couple of percentage prices it
actually has been a priority and and
jamie foxx who got an oscar for for ray
right uh
uh said uh in in in connection with this
oscar
uh so white movement he said
act better
be better
raise your game
don't demand don't yell don't scream get
better act better you got an oscar and
and and i think part of the reason he
said that is because
it kind of demeans his oscar
right because then it means you're
complaining that that oscars are so
white how did i get one
i was lucky yeah maybe just maybe i was
excellent yeah
so do you think that at times visibility
is important so for example i have i've
had jackie harry on here she was the
first black woman i think she won for
best supporting actress in 227
around i guess it's around 1989 or so at
that time do you think that a certain
amount of visibility may have been more
important than it is now right because
finally a black person did it even if
you don't think that the thing in and of
itself is is important i don't think so
i remember uh some years ago there was
an olympic black
skier named debbie uh debbie thomas i
believe was her last name and she was
the first
black olympiad in
in in ice skating
and she was constantly asked who are
your role models who are your role
models who inspired you and finally to
me out of out of exasperation she said i
don't need to see somebody black do
something before i think i can do it
and that's how i feel if i want to do
something
what's holding me back from doing it
other than my own
insecurities or
or or inadequacies just get up make it
happen yeah how exhausting is this
conversation to you i don't mean this
literal conversation right now but just
this thing you know so much of what you
talk about has to unfortunately be
framed around something that you don't
even think is is real you know what i
mean it's something that you think
should be put behind us that actually is
behind us and yet you have to talk about
it a lot just on a personal note how
does that feel for you doesn't bother me
i think there's a lot of feeling that
race and racism remain major problems in
america uh and i think that
that you're approaching this with with
with sincerity and and and since and
real concern uh i just don't think it's
that big of a deal yeah by the way i've
emailed dorae mckesson to have him on
who's the lead i think the quasi leader
of black lives matter he hasn't
responded but i will i will ask him
again so i'm not doing i'm not just
playing favorites here you know i'm just
putting that out no no problem
um
this is america there there are cubans
who are braving shark-infested waters to
get here there are people from central
america coming up here why do people
come here why do so many people want to
come to america and it's because it is
the land of the free and the home of the
brave it is a place where you can go
from nothing to something uh faster than
at any time uh and anywhere than in all
of human history that's why we're here
and
to me again you are
are almost giving the forefinger to all
the people who fought struggled worked
hard and died for people to sit around
in 2017 and [ __ ] moan and whine about
race and racism i am with a best-selling
author a radio host and a man who once
beat me senseless in front of millions
of people
larry elder welcome back to the reuben
report round two
well this will be round three how are
you this is so we're up to rocky iii
that's right
see but if it was rocky no no it's like
muhammad ali and frasier right ali lost
the first one frazier uh ali lost the
first one won the second one and then
they had the had the big third one
thrown in milo this is thrilling in
manila this is thrilling
right see i wish this was more like
rocky because in the original rocky they
it was to a standstill rocky one right
nobody wins rocky two rocky finally wins
and then three well at that point you're
retired i think ruben the only question
is which one of us is ali which one of
us is pleasure
we shall find out you'll find out all
right so uh you just sat down here but
we've already talked about comic books
about basketball
black panther yeah uh about racism about
uh trump uh i think we covered
everything bye
all right well let's do a little bit of
it for the people so i first i just want
to jump back to that original moment
because i said it to you last time you
were here which was about a year ago uh
and when that that moment where you
really beat me senseless about systemic
racism that was about two years ago
already if not more at this point and so
many people i was just in london two
days ago and i did a q a and people were
asking me about it i mean that thing
really
has there are many versions of it on
youtube it's just caught fire and as i
said to you last time it was sort of i
view it as my best moment and my worst
it was my worst because i came to a an
intellectual fight without the proper
equipment and it was my best because we
left it in and let it be and it was a
learning moment for me and then for
everyone else well you had a lot of
class for leaving it in a lot of people
would have would have taken it out and
no one would have known it happened and
secondly the older one gets the more
difficult it is for one to kind of
change one's beliefs and for you to do
it at your age to rethink your
assumptions uh uh takes a lot of a lot
of guts a lot of people don't want to do
that
it's a pretty depressing thing don't you
think i i agree with you most people
don't want to do it i think we've
fostered here something that is allowing
people to do it but most people don't
want to do that you know and it's funny
we're in an atmosphere where just a
moment ago i'm i'm driving in listening
to um
talk radio and i think it's cnn or msnbc
and they're going on and on about how
trump has now made lying uh the currency
of the day and and no one tells the
truth anymore facts don't matter and
they're talking about the kinds of lying
that trump does where he talks about the
crowd size and how much money he has and
stuff like that the lies of the left are
huge lies and they damage the country
the lie that racism remains a major
problem in america it's a lie the lie
that women make 77 cents on the dollar
for doing the same thing that men do
it's a lie the lie that rich get rich
the poor get poorer these are lies and
these are big lies that drive the left
and drive votes these are the kinds of
things that matter so when you sit
across from a guy like me and the first
time we did it when i really still felt
i was part of the left i was trying to
reform the left realistically i'm not
part of the left anymore you know and
again the left right thing as we talk
about all the time doesn't even have
that much meaning anymore it's really
about authoritarians and libertarians
and all that um
but for all the years that you've been
doing this staking out conservative
positions for how many years publicly 25
25 years
was there a more sensible left at the
time was there a guy you could sit
across from that you disagreed with
intellectually but felt that it was it
was forthright it was honest you just
disagreed with the methodology and the
results sure there were lots of people
that i felt that way with and william
buckley had a very good friend uh john
kenneth galbraith who was a left-wing
economist they disagreed about
everything they were good friends uh
believe it or not antoine scalia's best
friend on the supreme court is ruth
bader ginsburg what it requires is
somebody to recognize that if i have a
position that's different from yours it
doesn't mean that i'm a bad guy it
doesn't mean that i'm evil it means that
i see the world differently it takes a
certain kind of maturity to do that
unfortunately we've gotten to the place
now where if you don't believe that
racism is a major problem in america uh
if you're black you're a sellout if
you're white you're a racist if you say
something negative about the black
panther which i just did and just
tweeted i got hammered some some guy
told me that well it's because it's a
black person and a black director and a
black hero and therefore you don't like
it
i mean the star is guy named chadwick
boseman and i was fortunate enough to be
invited to see the premiere of 42. he
was brilliant i saw the movie three or
four times i like him so much i saw him
in
a movie about thurgood martial which was
a very good movie probably not
commercially uh
successful but it was a very good movie
and i saw him play in the movie with we
played james brown he was very good the
movie wasn't that good but he was good
yeah so he's an intriguing actor again i
don't go to see a movie to to not be
happy to waste my time yeah and you're a
comic book guy i mean the reason we were
talking about comic books is because
i've got a whole bunch in the green room
here and you were immediately going on
about all this stuff you loved so it's
not like you're walking into that thing
to hate it right and so the criticism is
just bizarre i mean
what do you think i am what do you think
i do i get up in the morning hate myself
gouge my eyeballs out try to claw my
skin color off and that's just
and and and dave i feel sorry for people
like that people have often asked me
does it make you mad it doesn't i feel
sorry for you if you are so trained so
indoctrinated to be that's rabid against
somebody who just has a different point
of view there's a problem with you not
with me you did it
you decided to get in the game
i had people begging me there's a
gajillion people out there like fix
california nobody ever no good people
decent people ever want to get in what
finally dragged you to do it so many
people like you
approached me and said why don't you do
this dennis prager first asked me and i
said
dennis hell no and he said why i said
california is practically ungovernable
we have two-thirds super majority in the
senate two-thirds super majority in the
assembly plus a left-wing governor the
the environmentalists run this state the
teachers union dominate the state it's
almost ungovernable hell no then it's
like oh okay i understand and then i got
approached by a guy named pastor jack
hibbs also a very good friend of mine
and he made the same argument dennis did
and then a friend of mine named lionel
chapman chetwin a longtime filmmaker
also made the same argument and then
just normal people that i know in my
life my gardener my the guy that drives
me from time to time the guy that opens
the door when i come into my uh to my
office buildings from time to time
people that were that i work with and
nobody said well larry geez you have a
great life and my goodness you're
starting to make money now and
and you've got a long time relationship
with your girlfriend nina why jeopardize
all that and nobody's lived a perfect
life and i'm sure you haven't too why
expose and no one said that i kept
waiting for somebody i respect to say
that
my mother and my father are no longer
with us uh my brother just died he was
my best friend he died september 13 2019
two weeks before his 70th birthday and i
know what he would have said he would
have said go for it that's just how he
is
my mom would have said go for it my dad
would have been more reluctant about my
own privacy and my own career but my
mother would have said go for it she's
been more political than i am so i
couldn't i ran out of reasons not to do
it and the more i watched gavin newsom
the more he ticked me off the way he was
sitting at that restaurant called the
french laundry
dave i never heard that restaurant until
he was there i thought it was probably
the most elite restaurant in california
it's not i thought it was the most elite
restaurant in america it's not it's one
of the most elite restaurants in the
world oh yeah an area sitting there
incurring a tab some people say it's 12
grand i heard it was as high as 30 grand
with the very medical professionals uh
and the lobbyists that drafted the
mandates that they were violating by not
wearing masks and by not socially
distancing at the height of lockdown
this wasn't two weeks and his two kids
were enjoying in-person private
education and he exempted his own winery
from the from the mandates and this kind
of arrogant smug entitled attitude
really started taking me off and then
you add to that the crime and the
homelessness
and the hellacious cost of living in
california larry you're scared to death
blown me away once or twice over the
years but are you telling me that the
conservatives are not racist are you are
you telling me that the conservatives
don't hate gay people and that the
conservatives generally want to live and
let live is that is that what you're
dropping that's what i'm saying most
people want people to realize their
potential why would it be in anybody's
best interest for a group of people to
be
to perceive
them as racist how is that making things
better don't you want everybody to be
law-abiding
drug abstaining tax-paying people
doesn't that make everything good
and whenever i ask people about systemic
racism i always say can you can you name
names what do you get david duke after
that after that the list is pretty short
isn't it give me the name who in
congress on the republican side is
systemically racist give me the name
give me the name and sometimes they say
trump are you kidding me
best economy ever under trump he
pardoned jack johnson the first black
heavyweight champion that obama didn't
do despite the fact that ken burns the
lefty uh documentarian came to obama and
said please pardon this guy didn't do it
sylvester stallone please pardon the guy
didn't do it trump does it he also uh
commuted the sense of a woman named
alice johnson who had done a very very
long trump hotel very long non-violent
drug offense uh he put permanent funding
of historically black colleges on for
10-year footing the one that had done
that before expanded opportunity zones
dropping some of the rules and
regulations in distressed areas so that
you you invite more business if he is a
racist he needs to go back to racism
school when you were watching the state
of the union and he mentioned lois black
unemployment of all time and then to
watch the congressional black caucus
right like to me that was everything
that you've preached about in your 40
years doing this how many years you've
been on here at this point 27 27 i gave
you an extra 14. but all of those black
don't crack and i know i know i look
really good
but but when you watch that moment it
must have just been like man i have been
screaming about this stuff here's the
guy doing this stuff and they dare sit
there but it's just one little example
they've been doing this for years uh
obama's mom sent him back from indonesia
when he's 10 years old to eventually go
to punahou the finest prep school in the
state of hawaii because she wanted him
to have better education michelle obama
did not go to a charter school they
didn't exist then but she did not go to
her local government school because it
was so bad she got on the bus and went
to a much better school ice cube the
rapper uh he didn't go to his local
government school he went to taft with
the time with predominantly white so
what are they telling you they're
telling you they want choice but you
don't get choice and they're beholden to
the teachers union that adamantly
opposes choice for all the reasons i
just now mentioned they don't get their
automatic dues from the teachers union
and therefore it threatens them they
couldn't care less about the quality of
education
and i mentioned the 300 000 teachers uh
in in
in
public school teachers in california and
the average year only 2.2 were fired
imagine
i told you between five and seven
percent of them are perceived to be
incompetent there are twenty thousand
cops here in in uh in l.a
imagine if five percent of them were bad
cops that's a thousand cops on the
streets we wouldn't put up with it we
put up with fifteen thousand bad
teachers
who wants to do something about that we
do they don't but i'm the bad guy i'm
the uncle tom think about it open up
your eyes who's on your side now the
beauty of our of our private ballots is
you can go in there
and your mailing ballot and you can vote
for a republican and nobody has to know
about it so i'm telling these
independents and democrats pull the
lever for me don't tell anybody
who's on your side i'm on your side i'm
gonna tell
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell